ja willkommen zu aktuellen Sitzung wie
immer gibt es zunächst ein Rückblick auf
die letzten Sitzung da hatten wir es mit
der kollektiven Person zu tun wir hatten
uns darüber unterhalten wir haben
diskutiert gibt es überhaupt Kollektiv
Personen juristische Personen gibt es
offensichtlich zumindest gibt es da
juristische Regelungen darüber sind
juristische Personen genau dasselbe wie
kollektivperson oder Plural subjects das
ist eine spannende Frage wir wollen auch
gar nicht die Frage danach hin jetzt
beantworten gibt sie oder gibt sie nicht
wir wollen einfach fragen welche Gründe
sprechen dafür davon auszugeben gehen
dass es sowas gibt oder nicht und wenn
es sowas gibt wie kann man sich dann
vorstellen dass sowas auch handelt gibt
noch mal eine Rückblick also wir haben
diese Fragen gestellt liefern sind
kollektive Personen auch schützenswert
können sie moralisch zur Rechenschaft
gezogen werden können sie juristisch zur
Rechenschaft gezogen werden wir haben
uns darüber unterhalten
strafrechtlich ist es nicht möglich eine
juristische Person irgendwie zu belangen
die Sommer denn auch an juristische
Person bestrafensommers jetzt Gefängnis
dann stecken also das geht dann auf die
Organe überall auf die Funktionären
Funktionäre die natürlichen Personen wir
haben uns überlegt was ist der
Unterschied zwischen individuellen
Personen Personen kollektiven also lose
organisierten Gruppen wie etwa Personen
Aggregate zum Beispiel sind Sie hier ein
Personen Aggregat die sind eine
losorganisierte Gruppe sie haben jetzt
keinen Vertrag untereinander
abgeschlossen dass Sie hier regelmäßig
in die Vorlesung kommen zumindest ist
mir keiner solche bekannt es könnte sein
dass dazwischen ihn irgendwie Verträge
kursieren und dann werden sie vielleicht
sogar mehr als eine endloses
personenkollektiv aber ich gehe davon
aus dass das nicht der Fall ist
und um eine kollektivperson zu sein wir
fassen die jetzt auch mal juristische
Person da muss einfach noch viel mehr im
Hintergrund geschehen sein da muss man
ein Verein sein aber man muss Organe
besitzen und man ist als solches auch
Träger von Rechten und Pflichten
für eine können handeln und ich habe
erzählt sie können auch was Erben das
ist also ganz spannend häufig ist es bei
Tierschutzverein so dass diese häufig
dann etwas Erben und Erben können
natürlich auch natürliche Personen also
sie alle können auch was Erben das ist
also eine ganz interessante Sache da
gibt es erst mal eine Analogie zwischen
juristischen Personen zwischen
natürlichen Person jetzt gibt es zwei
Auffassungen die hatte ich auch
vorgestellt fiktionalismus und der sagt
kollektivpersonen so kann man zwar reden
als ob aber das sind eigentlich bloße
Fiktionen einmal tut das so als würde da
so ein künstlich erzeugtes kollektives
Subjekt in der Welt agieren in die Welt
eingreifen das sind bloß angenommene
Subjekte ja nur als ob Fiktion so sah
der gut aus und dann gibt es die
entgegengesetzte Auffassung das ist der
Realismus
orthopädieke der sagt kollektivpersonen
sind ein selbstständig in die Außenwelt
eingreifendes Subjekt
ein ganzes mit über Individualität also
sie können nicht
ohne Bedeutungsverlust zumindest
reduziert werden die kollektivperson auf
die einzelne Person natürlich kann man
besuchen eine kollektivperson zu
reduzieren wir haben darüber diskutiert
ist es nur ein epistemisches Problem als
ein erkenntnistheoretisches Problem dass
wir gar nicht mehr im Einzelnen
nachverfolgen können wie die Individuen
interagieren um dann die
kollektivversion zu bilden aber Otto von
Gehrke sagt es ist nicht nur ein
erkenntnistheoretisches Problem sondern
es ist ein ontologisches Problem unter
logisch heißt es betrifft die Existenz
wir können gar nicht aus Gründen der
Existenz eine Kollektiv Person
reduzieren auf ihre natürlich
also das geht nicht das ontologisches
Problem sie werden die Begriffe
Ontologie in Epistemologie immer wieder
hören also Ontologie betrifft einfach
das sein die Existenz von griechisch und
das heißt scient und lockers die Lehre
und Epistemologie das ist die Episteme
das heißt die Erkenntnis epistellen
Urologie die Lehre von der Erkenntnis
und das sind so Perspektiven die man auf
ganz verschiedene Dinge werfen kann man
kann auch Handlungen aus einer
ontologischen Perspektive betrachten das
machen wir heute wenn wir zum Beispiel
uns jetzt im zweiten Teil der heutigen
Vorlesung die Frage stellen aus welchen
Teilen Handlungen bestehen also man kann
Handlungen
als etwas Seiendes verstehen ich sage
jetzt nicht als ein Ding das wäre nicht
adäquat ich kann Handlungen nicht
verstehen in der Analogie zu dieser
Fernbedienung das geht nicht warum nicht
weil Handlung erstrecken sich Handlungen
haben eine zeitliche Ausdehnung und die
meisten Philosophen und Philosophen
sagen dass eine Fernbedienung keine
zeitliche ausstreckung hat manche sagen
das es gibt zum Beispiel
vierdimensionalismus der existiert das
Ding immer in Zeitscheiben sozusagen ja
also es ist existiert nicht nur räumlich
sondern eben auch noch zeitlich darüber
solange wie das Ding eben existiert das
wäre der vierdimensionalismus müssen wir
uns gar nicht Größen mit befassen ich
wollte nur sagen man kann von Dingen
immer auch unter dem Gesichtspunkt ihre
Existenz sprechen und so kann man es
auch eben von kollektivperson tun und
auch von Handlung kann man aus einer
ontologischen Perspektive reden so
jedenfalls noch mal zurück zu Otto von
Gierke der sagt also Kollektiv und sind
etwas was nicht reduziert werden kann
auf die einzelnen Person dann haben wir
wieder Umfrage gemacht über Elias damals
hat Elias noch funktioniert und
so sah dieser
QR-Code aus und sie haben fleißig mit
gestimmt 56
teilnehmende und es war recht klar die
Intuition zwei Drittel ziemlich genau
zwei Drittel sagt ja wir haben gute
Intuitionen davon auszugehen dass sowas
wie eine kollektivperson existiert und
ein Drittel hat gesagt nein das ist
nicht plausibel von einer Existenz
auszugehen man hätte jetzt weiter fragen
können diejenigen die jetzt gegen die
Auffassung sind dass es
kollektivpersonen gibt die hier mit Nein
gestimmt haben was waren die Argumente
für das nein da gibt es verschiedene
Gründe man kann zum Beispiel sagen ja es
sind bloße Fiktionen man kann sagen die
kollektivperson ist eben nicht mehr als
die Summe der Teile sondern sie ist halt
nur die und um Summen zu verstehen muss
ich die einzelnen Teile verstehen und
dann kann ich alles damit erklären also
es gibt verschiedene Argumente eben ob
wir die Gegenposition die haben wir
jetzt aber nicht weiter behandelt das
war nur so eine Intuition die ich
aufgreifen wollte und jetzt haben wir
uns gefragt wie Handeln Kollektiv Person
wir kommen auch heute noch mal
ausführlich auf den Handlungsbegriff zu
sprechen der steht heute im Zentrum also
wichtig ist das individuelle Person sich
durch Verpflichtungen komm mit nennst
das ist dieser Begriff joint commitment
haben wir gesehen
gemeinsame Ziele gemeinsame Absichten
gemeinsam Interessen dass ich zusammen
lesen und sich auch sprachlich darauf
einigen das führt wieder zum nächsten
Thema wenn ich mich sprachlich auf etwas
einigen kann dann kann ich auch mit
meiner Sprache Handeln bekommen auch
noch eigens auf sprachhandlung zu
sprechen aber es ist ein ganz
alltägliches Phänomen dass sie sich mit
anderen Menschen
durch gemeinsame Interessen verbindet
und dass sie das Gefühl haben
wir sind alle derselben mein das kann
natürlich nicht in jeder Hinsicht sein
aber es ist ein partielles Interesse
also kollektivpersonen gibt es in ganz
verschiedener Hinsicht und man spricht
die häufige von Plural subjects um eine
juristische Person zu bilden da gehört
mehr dazu als nur ein gemeinsames
Interesse da müssen sie dann auch
natürlich juristisch das ganze eintragen
vielleicht im Handelsregister und so
weiter wenn es eine privates Unternehmen
ist da sind mehr Hürden sind da der
ganzen Sache gesetzt aber auf basaler
Ebene wenn man von Plural Subjekten
spricht jetzt nicht von dem
anspruchsvolleren Begriff einer
juristischen Person von Plural also
Decken wenn Sie sich mit anderen
Personen über einer Sache einig sind und
dass eine gewisse Verbindlichkeit
besitzt eine gewisse Stabilität und sie
gemeinsam
übereinstimmen dann was tun dann kann
man schon sagen da hat sich irgendwas
neues gebildet ein Plural Subjekt
ja dann gibt es kollektives
beabsichtigen kollektive Intentionalität
man kann also alles was man auf mit
Blick von einzelnen Subjekten sagen kann
mit Individuen was die tun was die
beabsichten sich gegen das kann man auch
irgendwie von kollektiven Subjekten
sagen oder kollektiven Personen man
setzt einfach immer davor Kollektiv also
kollektives beabsichtigen kollektive
Intentionalität
kollektives verpflichten kollektives
Handeln es gibt auch sowas wie joint
attention also gemeinsame Aufmerksamkeit
die einer Sache entgegengebracht wird an
da gibt es ganz verschiedene Phänomen
und jetzt hatte ich noch hinzugefügt so
meine These also Handlungen kollektiver
Personen oder von Plural Subjekten sind
tendenziell eher träge da sie von
komplexen kollektiven Verfahren der
Entscheidungsfindung abhängig sind also
wenn sie mal im Vereinen wenn sie mal
Vereine sich anschauen oder auch starten
oder sonstige
Kollektiv Phänomene bis die mal handeln
das geht in der Regel nicht so spontan
sie können als natürliche Person viel
schneller viel spontaner Handeln ich
würde mal behaupten solchen juristischen
Personen geht die Spontanität auf dem
Begriff kann man auch noch zur
Spontanität bedeutet von selbst aus ein
Prozess zu initiieren und zwar eben mehr
oder weniger auch von jetzt auf nachher
dieses Spontanität die fehlt so ein
bisschen diesen kollektivperson aufgrund
des Verfahrens was hinter den ganzen
Handlungen steht man muss sich einigen
müssen gewisse Regeln auch beachtet
werden das heißt auch die Gründe die zur
Handlung führen Gründe können auch
regeln sein die sind bei
kollektivpersonen viel komplexer als es
bei uns individuellen Personen sind
darüber kann man natürlich aber auch
noch mal genau diskutieren eine
juristische Person handelt durch ihre
Organe haben wir gesagt den Vorstand
Mitgliedsversammlung und im Strafrecht
sind dann eben auch die einzelnen
Personen der verantwortlich die Organ
baldschaftliche Straftat nicht die
juristischen Personen sind jetzt alles
beim juristische Terminologie
haben Sie noch Fragen zu dieser letzten
Sitzung da kann man eine kurze
diskussionspause einlegen falls nicht
würde ich jetzt weitergehen zur heutigen
Sitzung und da geht es jetzt um was ganz
spannendes nämlich um die Frage was eine
Handlung eigentlich ist und das ist
nämlich auch nicht ganz klar wir sind
immer schon ein bisschen darauf
eingegangen wir wollen zuerst uns fragen
was es eine basishandlung
haben Sie wahrscheinlich noch nie gehört
hat jemand von ihnen schon mal eine
basishandlung vollzogen nee oder also
eine Handlung haben sie mal vollzogen
aber eine basishandlung seltsam also
spricht man eigentlich nicht Alter was
meine basishandlung vollzieht wir wollen
uns auf den Begriff konzentrieren dann
wollen wir uns fragen was ist eine
komplexe Handlung also basishandlung und
komplexe Handlung die stehen irgendwie
so ein bisschen im Gegensatz oder sie ja
sind nicht genau dasselbe dann wollen
wir uns befassen mit handlungsversuchen
ist ein handlungsversuch auch eine
Handlung
wahrscheinlich nicht ja aber es ist
kommt sehr nahe an eine Handlung weil
diese ganze Phänomenologie also nennt
man die den
erscheinungserscheinungsreichtum von
handeln dann mich persönlich sehr
interessieren die Frage sind
Unterlassungen auch Handlungen das ist
eine juristisch ganz spannende Frage
darüber werden heute diskutieren
das ist jetzt so die Frage und jetzt
möchte ich mal ganz allgemein erstmal
Sie Fragen dann machen wir jetzt auch
eine kurze diskussionspause jetzt habe
ich immer so um den heißen Brei
rumgeredet jetzt möchte ich sie
eigentlich mal fragen was eigentlich
ihre Auffassung nach eine Handlung
ist darauf möchte ich jetzt gerne zu
sprechen kommen
und jetzt möchte ich mal hier ein ein
Angebot geben das ist wie alles hier in
dieser Vorlesung immer diskutabel
darüber können wir treffen streiten
was könnte eine kollektive Handlung sein
also
ich habe jetzt mal gesagt Handlungen
sind kausale Verwirklichungen unsere
Absichten und Intentionen
ich habe verschiedene Absichten und
Ziele Intentionen
aber ich kann nur wenige umsetzen oder
realisieren das also mein Wunsch Bilder
oder was auch immer meine Absicht dass
die verwirklicht wird
und wichtig ist eben auch die kausale
Verwirklichung wobei das eigentlich
doppelt ist ja eine Verwirklichung ist
immer was kausales
ja jetzt kann man sich jeder noch genau
überlegen es machen wir auch noch was
für eine Art von Kausalität ist das ja
wenn sie mal genau hinschauen da gibt es
dann eigentlich zwei Arten von
Kausalität einmal eine Kausalität die
von meinem Kopf ausgeht also von meinem
geistigen Zuständen meine Wünsche meine
Absichten die entfaltene Kausalität das
nennt man die mentale Verursachung
mentale Kausalität und wenn ich jetzt
dann was tue in der Welt meistens kommt
man ja von der Handlung zur Hand und
meine Hand bewege dann ist es natürlich
auch noch eine eigene Kausalität all die
Wirkung die wirkt Kausalität sagt man
die krause infizienz wir kommen noch auf
die verschiedenen
kausalitätsarten zu sprechen
also es gibt verschiedene Arten von
Kausalität wir haben uns auch schon
Gedanken gemacht zwischen über Gründe
und Ursachen ja
häufig sagt man Gründe die für etwas
sprechen die haben alle kausale Wirkung
aber sie sind nicht genau dasselbe wie
jetzt Natur Ursachen weil man die
Intuition hat dass wenn ich handle nicht
nur ich dem Naturgesetz Folge sondern
dass ich mich aus Freiheit für etwas
entschieden habe ja also die Gründe die
zu der Handlung führen die liegen jetzt
sagen wir zumindest meistens nicht im
Urknall versohlen so viel Milliarden
Jahren direkt der Urknall mag natürlich
was mit unserer Handlung zu tun haben
aber in der Regel sagen wir ich habe die
Gründe die liegt in mir die liegen nicht
im Urknall versuchen so viel Milliarden
also Gründe und Ursache eigenes Thema
noch ja aber das wollen wir sagen
kausale Verwirklichung von Absichten
Intention es bleibt nicht nur bei der
Absicht beim frommen Wunsch sondern wir
tun es sie kennen vielleicht den Spruch
wir kommen noch drauf zu sprechen es
gibt nichts Gutes außer man tut es haben
Sie vielleicht schon mal gehört
also man muss dann aber was tun und
nicht immer nur hier vorne Absicht gab
also ich würde gerne das tun und das tun
sie kennen das vielleicht auch von sich
aber dann sagt man ihn ja dann tust doch
mal ja und das ist die Handlung wenn man
es tut und häufig kann man da gar nicht
so genau unterscheiden viele mich
eingeschlossen denkt manchmal ja gut mit
einer Absicht ist doch schon geschehen
da habe ich doch schon gehandelt ja ist
eben nicht man kann natürlich darüber
diskutieren das machen wir auch noch
gleich ist nicht das Fassen eine Absicht
das Entwickeln einer Absicht selbst
schon eine Hand
ist man darüber diskutieren am Handlung
ergeben sich aus dem Zusammenspiel von
Wille fasse ich jetzt mal ganz weit auf
also von Wünschen von
willensstrebungen und Rationalität und
sie sind sofern Ausdruck unserer
Freiheit ich komme jetzt gleich noch ein
bisschen genauer darauf zu sprechen was
ich damit gemeint der Wille im weitesten
Sinne könnte man sich vorstellen liefert
die Energie und die Motivation also
sozusagen die Materie da ist so die
Energie dahinter das ist ihre Triebkraft
wenn man spricht auch häufig von
Wünschen Triebe und Begierde bei
Begierden da hat man das gleich eine
Begierde die hat ganz viel Kraft
ein Trieb auch ein Trieb ist auch häufig
was was in anderen Kontexten verwendet
wird ein Antrieb zum Beispiel ein Motor
hat ein Antrieb und Motivation da steckt
ja auch Motor drin oder das hängt
zumindest mit dem Wort zusammen das
Bewegung ja Bewegung Dynamik das ist so
dass die Materie mal sagen und die
Rationalität ist der zweite Bestandteil
der zu einer Handlung gehört auch im
weitesten Sinne die Rationalität liefert
die Orientierung die Begründung
Bewertung Anleitung also gewissermaßen
die Form
hat es jetzt noch ganz allgemein aber so
kann man sich auf den ersten Blick für
die erste Annäherung weil vorstellen
Rationalität die die kann unsere Willens
Energie das was den des energiegetische
des Willens bedeutet ordnet die kann den
Willen konzentrieren wenn sie jetzt nur
wieder im weitesten Sinne Sinne
irgendwelche willenstendenzen in sich
haben dann haben Sie vielleicht
begierten Antriebe aber diese Begierden
und Antriebe die können sich auch
entgegengesetzt sein und dann stellt
sich die Frage für sie aber welcher
Begierde soll ich jetzt folgen und
welche nicht und dann fragen Sie hier
gleich nach der Orientierung der
Begründung welche Begierde ist denn
jetzt gut und welche nicht gut die
Begierde als solche sagt es nicht
Begierde Begier begehrt so kann man eine
nicht sprechen aber ich mache es jetzt
einfach mal die Begierde interessiert
sich nicht dafür was sie begehrt sind
sie begehrt einfach und darin besteht
die Begierde
das heißt der Begierde oder dem Willen
fehlt eigentlich so eine Reflexivität
und wenn sie was wollen wünschen wenn
sie auf etwas hin Streben dann gehen Sie
ganz in dem Streben auf und sie
verhalten sich nicht noch mal zu sich im
Strebe
so fasse ich jetzt mal den Willen im
weitesten Sinne auf und wir sagen
eigentlich wir handelt der muss sich
schon da auch mal Gedanken gemacht
darüber haben was er eigentlich will und
wonach strebt und und Handlung
resultiert dann daraus dass wir in
unserem Begehren uns über unsere
Begehren klar werden und dadurch manche
Begierden oder manches Wünsche
willensrichtungen anderen überordnen
oder unterordnen das heißt wir bringen
Reflexivität Reflexion wäre auch noch so
ein Punkt den ich hier in der
Rationalität mit reinnehmen könnte ja
orientieren Begründung Bewertung
anleitet und in diesem Zusammenspiel
dazu da kommen wir dann zu Handlung und
zur Rationalität kann man jetzt eben
Sinne die moralische Rationalität zählen
moralische Rationalität ist zum Beispiel
dass ich mich frage was ist eigentlich
moralisch gut und dass ich eine
Begründung dafür immer habe warum etwas
gut oder etwas böse ist das beste
Beispiel ist Immanuel Kant sie haben
alle schon mal den kategorischen
Imperativ gehört ja handle so dass die
Maxime deines Willens jederzeit zugleich
als Prinzip eine allgemein Gesetzgebung
dienen könnte so kompliziert dass es
natürlich nichts was jetzt der Wille und
sagt sind das sagt uns die Vernunft zu
einem komplexe Formel eine Maximen Test
wie man bei Kant noch sehen wird das ist
eine Sache der Rationalität es gibt
moralische Rationalität dass ich nicht
dass ich rechtfertigen kann warum jetzt
das gut ist oder nicht das wieder
Orientierung und es gibt auch
instrumentelle Rationalität wenn ich
etwas zum Mittel eines zwecks
benutze
man muss diese zwei Formen von
Rationalität unterscheiden
mittelzweckrationalität begegnen uns
alltäglich ich mache etwas um ein
anderes Ziel zu erreichen manchmal muss
ich mir überlegen welche Schritte muss
ich jetzt einleiten damit ich das
erreiche
das Problem der instrumentellen
Rationalität ist es dass die häufig
nicht moralisch interessiert ist es
hängt einfach nur vom gegebenen Zweck ab
den Zweck hinterfragt die instrumentelle
Rationalität nicht sie haben einfach ein
Zweck und wenn der Zweck jetzt
vorgegeben ist dann folgt die
instrumentelle Vernunft und gibt ihm die
einzelnen Handlungsanweisung um zu
diesem Zweck zu kommen wir hatten das
schon gesehen bei Manuel Kant ist es der
hypothetische Imperativ also der
Imperativ die Handlungsanweisung unter
einem bestimmten Gesetzen Zweck ob der
Zweck jetzt moralisch gut oder böse oder
was auch immer ist wird hier gar nicht
weiter hinterfragen es geht einfach nur
darum wie komme ich jetzt zu Zweck und
das ist die sind die hypothetischen
Imperativ also ich wollte nur sagen wir
brauchen immer auch Rationalität ich
habe jetzt nicht den Begriff der
Vernunft gebracht könnte man auch
bringen Kontext der Rationalität wir
brauchen beides wir brauchen irgendwie
energiestrebungen Interessen und wir
brauchen zugleich Reflexion diese
Interessen Orientierung Begründung
Gründe habe ich den ersten Fall das wäre
der Wille ohne Rationalität auch ein
bisschen schematisch also Strebungen in
die sich durchsetzen
ohne Rationalität sprich ohne Begründung
ohne Gründe ohne Reflexion groß ohne
moralische Erwägung und so weiter da
könnte man als bloße Willkür bezeichnen
wir sind den Begriff schon begegnet
ich tue einfach was weil der Wille in
mir so stark ist und die Interessen
haben jetzt einfach gesiegt ja die
willenswaage hat zu der einen Seite
geneigt und dann tue ich es halt so da
wird gar nicht groß darüber nachgedacht
es wäre die bloße für Wille oder
Rationalität und es gibt so einen
zweiten Fall Rationalität ohne Wille das
ist schon komplexer also
die haben irgendwie Überzeugungen etwas
gute Gründe
tun dann aber etwas willentlich was wir
gar nicht für überzeugend halten ja also
Handeln wieder besseres Wissen sowas
gibt es auch das nennt man dann die
Willensschwäche da wird meine eigene
Sitzung dazu haben aggressiva ist auch
zum Beispiel also es gibt verschiedene
Phänomene in unserem Alltag wo Wille und
Rationalität nicht so im Einklang
miteinander sind wo wir innerlich
irgendwie zerrissen sind wo wir nicht
glücklich sind in unserem Handel wo
unser Handel nicht gelingt und es
passiert uns leider häufig im Alltag
dass wir nicht wirklich zu einer
Handlung finden können und es hat
verschiedene Gründe und es muss auch die
praktische Philosophie natürlich immer
diskutieren was sind die Gründe wenn
unser Handeln scheitern
also es kann an zwei Stellen Problem
geben das einfach Wille entweder zu
stark betont wird oder Rationalität dass
die beiden nicht in einer Harmonie
stehen und die Handlung scheint
voraussetzen dass beide Anteile oder
Momente in einer Einheit sind das heißt
um zu handeln ist eine rationale
Willensbildung nötig
rationale Willensbildung also ein Wille
liegt nicht einfach nur vor der Regel
und dann folgt die Handlung daraus ich
meine meistens ist ein Wille was
handlungswirksames ein Wille ist etwas
was entschieden ist aber in der Regel
sind sie wenn sie handeln davor nicht
schon immer entschieden gewesen es gibt
nur ganz selten den Fall wo sie sagen da
muss ich gar nicht groß drüber
nachdenken das mache ich sofort wenn sie
so eine Situation haben dann haben sie
schon der Vergangenheit in ähnlichen
Situationen drüber nachgedacht und dann
ist das praktisch nur ein Fall ein
ähnlicher Fall wo sie dann übertragen
können aus der Vergangenheit auf die
jetzige Situation in der Regel müssen
Sie bevor Sie handeln viel nachgedacht
haben ja es gibt schwierigere
Entscheidungen und leichtere
Entscheidung es kann schneller geschehen
oder es kann länger dauern ich bringe
eben noch mal das Beispiel die
Entscheidung einen ein Studium in
Angriff zu nehmen das ist eine ganz
komplexe Willensbildung da müssen ganz
viele Interessen müssen da einfließen
und von diesen Entscheidungen hängt dann
doch einiges ab man kann auch ein
Studium noch mal neu beginnen abbrechen
ist alles möglich aber es dann auch
wieder abzubrechen ist eine setzt eine
ganz
komplexe Willensbildung voraus da müssen
sie mit sich selbst ins Gespräch kommen
da holen Sie die Meinung anderer
Menschen mit allen Freunde Familie da
diskutieren Sie mit sich da wird
reflektiert und diese Willensbildung
erfolgt durch deliberation also der
liberation heißt Abwägen von Gründen ja
also was spricht dafür was spricht
dagegen deliberieren
ist natürlich auch ein Prozess der auf
Freiheit passiert ja das ist so dieses
in die Waagschale werfen was hat dieser
Grund für ein Gewicht und diese das
Abwägen von Gründen und das setzt man
eigentlich voraus von der Handlung der
Handlung braucht in verschiedenen
geraden jedenfalls auch eine Handlung
braucht eine Form von der liberation
sonst ist es keine wirkliche Behandlung
muss begründet sein ohne der liberation
also dieses Abwägen von Gründen wir
haben noch eine eigene Vorlesung nur zum
Thema Wassergrund ist darüber könnte man
eine ganze Vorlesung machen
eine deliberation also dieser Prozess
des Abwägens von Gründen kann dadurch
beendet werden dass sie mich bewusst für
eine Handlungsoption entscheidet
man kann sich nämlich Fragen ja wie kann
ich denn überhaupt aus einer solchen
deliberativen ja Situationen
herauskommen es gibt doch permanenten
neue Gründe ja wie kann ich denn
bitteschön aus diesem ewigen Kreislauf
des Überlegens unsere flektieren es
rauskommt ich kann sagen dafür
entscheide mich dann gibt es aber sofort
wieder ein Grund der dagegen spricht ja
und jetzt könnte man sich fragen ist
denn dann das Beenden eines solchen der
liberationsprozesses nicht irgendwas
ganz willkürliches im schlechten Sinne
dass ich einfach sagt also jetzt haben
wir aber 18:30 Uhr und jetzt ist schluss
jetzt habe ich Feierabend natürlich auch
zu teleporieren sehr natürlich wieder
Grund ja ist das bloß willkürlich wie
komme ich denn zu einem
Entscheidungspunkt sondern definitiven
Entscheidung wenn ich doch prinzipiell
eigentlich immer der reparieren muss
das werden wir auch diskutieren aber so
viel steht fest ich muss mich irgendwann
entscheiden mit der liberation muss
irgendwann mal Schluss sein sonst komme
ich nicht zu einer Handlung und dann
fasse ich einen Schluss und dann ist
dieser Entschluss verbindlich zumindest
für eine gewisse Zeit weil nämlich dann
die Handlung jetzt kann man sich fragen
kann ich auch manchmal einen schlussfall
Fällen und dann voll keine Hand aus ich
habe mich jetzt entschlossen etwas zu
tun und tue es aber trotzdem nicht
ist es dann ein handlungsversuch dann
könnte man sagen ist ein
handlungsversuch also setzt ein
handlungsversuch einen Schluss voraus
oder haben wir es mit einem Fall von
Willensschwäche zu tun ich will einfach
nur mal die Probleme anreisen die hier
an den Spiel kommen Entscheidungen sind
in der Regel begründet und können im
Rahmen einer Geschichte gerechtfertigt
werden das haben wir schon alles
besprochen wenn sich fürs Studium
entscheiden dann hat jeder von ihnen
seine individuellen Gründe und die
Gründe Folgen einer Geschichte ja Sie
können sagen als ich mal kleiner war
habe ich schon diese Interessen gehabt
und dann bin ich dieser Person begegnet
das heißt häufig autobiographische
autobiographisch heißt aber nicht dass
das bloß beliebig ist und das sind gute
Gründe ihre Interessen dann haben sie
gesagt dann habe ich in der Schule
dieses Fach so gern gehabt dann habe ich
eine gute Lehrerin gehabt in diesem Fach
und ich wollte immer schon das werden
und wenn Sie das in eine kohärente
Geschichte
ein packen das können sie schon
aufschreiben das machen auch manchen ihr
Autobiografien das sind die Gründe ihres
Lebens dann wird man ihre Handlung
völlig verstehen können selbst wenn man
sagt ich würde nie Philosophie studieren
also ich würde das nie tun aber ich kann
total gut verstehen dass du vor diesem
Hintergrund Philosophie studiert hast
völlig jeder hatte andere Ziele und das
kann man wenn man das begründet völlig
verstehen hingegen wieder unser
beliebtes Beispiel wenn sie jetzt
schreiben ich habe die Münze geworfen
Kopf oder Zahl und es kam Kopf raus und
dann habe ich eben Philosophie studiert
statt
Mathematik
da würde es einigen Menschen schwer
fallen sie zu verstehen da würden dann
manche Leute sagen
hat das wirklich jetzt eine Entscheidung
es sei denn sie würden sagen ich bin
aber genau gleich fähig ich bin zu 50%
fähig Philosophie zu studieren und genau
zu 50 Prozent fähig Mathematik zu
studieren es sind genau die Gründe
halten sich genau Gleichgewicht ich habe
alle Gründe die mir zur Verfügung
standen in die jeweiligen Waagschalen
geworfen und ich habe genau auf die
Skala geschaut und die Waage war genau
im Gleichgewicht ich habe so viele
Gründe reingeworfen wir sind alle Gründe
jetzt ausgegangen ich habe keine Gründe
mehr und die Waagschale steht auf 50 50
und in so einer Situation wusste nichts
besseres als eine Münze zu werfen
ich denke das könnte man verstehen sogar
in so einem Fall das könnte man könnte
man klar also ich würde das
nachvollziehen wenn die Person mir
glaubhaft versichern kann dass sie
wirklich zu 50 Prozent des ein oder das
andere wählen kann und dass das wird
genau dieselben Gründe sprechen in ihrer
Gewichtigkeit dann fände ich das völlig
okay ja aber so eine gleich gleich
schwäbigkeit gleich Pendelei gibt es in
der Regel nur selten oder man hat nicht
lange genug darüber nachgedacht
kollektive Handlung haben wir schon
genug jetzt behandelt die werden durch
komplexe institutionelle Vorgänge
initiiert oder auch begründet Wahlen
Geschäftsordnung an Date werden sie
beschlossen und Organe zum Beispiel
Vorstand ausgeführt er wird auch häufig
delegiert und das Ganze ist ziemlich
träge in der Regel ist seit es gibt ein
Eilverfahren aber ein Eilverfahren muss
man wieder dann irgendwie anmelden oder
begründen und man muss immer wieder den
anderen Rechenschaft ablegen müssen
Rechenschaftsbericht mussten
Rechenschaft ablegen ja Geschäftsbericht
muss eine Kostenübersicht bei Vereinen
wie viel haben wir eingenommen wie viel
haben wir ausgegeben ständig muss
gerechtfertigt werden ja ist anstrengend
kollektives Handeln kann sehr
anstrengend sein und es wird die
Analogien zu individuellen handeln die
hören auch irgendwo mal
ja kollektive Handlungen kollektiven
Handlungen liegt eine
institutionalisierte kollektive
Willensbildung zugrunde ein sogenanntes
joint commitment das hatte ich Ihnen
gezeigt anhand dieser Bücher von
Margaret Gilbert die einen sehr
bedeutende Philosophin zu diesem Thema
ist joint commitment wird uns nur ab und
zu begegnen so und jetzt
möchte ich mal so ein bisschen konkreter
werden jetzt gehen wir mal so ein
bisschen auf individuelle Handlung
zurück und jetzt möchte ich ihn mal so
ein paar Fälle von möglichen Handlungen
vorstellen es war mal ganz konkret
darüber diskutieren also ich bewege
meinen Arm so
ist das eine Handlung
also das Beispiel war ich bewege mein
Arm es muss irgendwie eine Absicht damit
verbunden sein sonst ist das ganze
irgendwie
ja nicht ganz verständlich ich
entschließe mich etwas zu tun ist das
eine Handlung also ich tue es jetzt
nicht wenn ich etwas tue dann ist es
eine Handlung aber ich entschließe mich
etwas zu tun ist der Entschluss auch
eine Handlung bring noch ein Beispiel
ich löse ein Kreuzworträtsel
ist das eine Handlung
ich finde schon ja also Kreuzworträtsel
lösen
ich denke sehr viel denken aber da muss
ich eintragen muss ich vielleicht nicht
mal eintragen könnte ich auch im Kopf
mehr merken es gibt sicherlich Menschen
die ein Kreuzworträtsel lösen können
ohne die
Lösungswörter reinzuschreiben die haben
dann ein hervorragendes Gedächtnis ja
also ich muss nicht unbedingt das
Kreuzworträtsel so lösen dass ich die
Buchstaben rein schreibe die Wörter aber
ich muss sehr viel denken ich würde
sagen es eine Handlung ich schließe mich
etwas zu tun da würde ich jetzt intuitiv
erstmal sagen nein keine Handlung weil
der Entschluss ja die Bedingung für eine
Handlung ist
es könnte vielleicht seine ist dann ein
handlungsversuch
jetzt kommen auf basishandlungen zu
sprechen was ist eine basishandlung
Handlungen sind in der Regel komplexe
Prozesse die aus verschiedenen Teil bzw
basishandlungen bestehen
also sind praktisch
Atome also die unendlich weiter
analysierbaren Grundbestandteile einer
Handlung
basishandlungen konstituieren komplexe
Handlungen und die werden selbst nicht
mehr ihrerseits konstituierten die sind
einfach so wie sie sind also sie sind
ihre reduzible Momente komplexere
Handlung man könnte auch sagen ihr
reduzierten Handlungsschritte
Handlungsschritt gefällt mir gut weil
man könnte sagen eine Handlung ist ein
Prozess ja Handlung
konstituiert sich durch verschiedene
basishandlungen die Folien mache ich
Ihnen noch zur Verfügung zur Verfügung
Beispiel ein Kuchen backen
sie wollen sich jetzt eine
Schwarzwälder Kirschtorte backen
so jetzt können sich mein aller Ruhe
überlegen was für basishandlungen also
nicht weiter reduziertle
Teilhandlungen sie dazu vollziehen
müssen um diese Schwarzwälder
Kirschtorte
zu backen das ist gar nicht trivial sind
ziemlich viele Teilschritte
ich möchte jetzt mal ein Versuch wagen
eine basishandlung zu isolieren und zwar
wäre das Anschalten des Backofens das
ist auch Teil dieses Backens der
Schwarzwälder Kirschtorte ganz klar
jetzt wenn ich jetzt gesagt hätte eine
basishandlung ist
die Torte in den Backofen zu stellen
wäre das eine basishandlung hier
schüttelt schon jemand zurecht den Kopf
nein weil das hineinstellen in den
Backofen voraussetze ich muss den
Backofen erst öffnen das sind wieder
viele basishandlungen im Spiel ich muss
das Backblech
rausziehen also wo ist es Hochton ich
muss den Kuchen gleich rein und macht
den Backofen wieder zu das heißt wir
haben hier
selbst bei sowas banalen wie den Kuchen
in den Ofen stellen also es gibt ja
häufig so Backanleitung ja stellen Sie
den Kuchen in den Ofen gut man kann
sagen der Ofen ist schon offen dann
stelle ich ihn rein aber auch hier
sind genau besehen noch viele andere
Teilhandlungen der Fall deswegen würde
ich jetzt mal bevor wir gleich kurz
darüber diskutieren sagen eine
basishandlung wäre das Anschalten des
Backofen das liegt min ich drehe das
ganze und ich drücke vielleicht gibt es
solche Backofen wo ich nur ein Schalter
umlegen das kann es ja geben ja wäre das
eine basishandlung und jetzt kann man
sich noch eine andere Frage stellen ist
eine Handlung mehr als die Summe ihrer
basishandlung ähnlich wie der bei
kollektivpersonen und individuelle
Person kann man das reduzieren kann ich
also sagen die Handlung eine
schwarzwälte Kirschtorte backen ist
gleich mache ich so eine Summen Klammer
auf oder wie auch immer eine Liste und
sagt das dass das das und zwar in
zeitlicher Abfolge also die
basishandlung die müssen natürlich nicht
zeitliche Ordnung haben wenn ich jetzt
irgendwie den Backofen gleich am Anfang
anschalte und dann dann passt es ich
könnte ihn schon am Anfang anschalten
vielleicht um den Backofen vorzuwerben
und so ja aber irgendwie kann ich manche
Schritte nicht umkehren ja also da gibt
es gewisse Logiken des Aufbaus
ich kann zum Beispiel nicht mit der
Kirche beginnen ja ich kann nicht die
Kirche ja oben da reinkommt vielleicht
je nachdem wo jetzt die Schwarzwälder
Kirschtorte ihre Tradition hat
gibt es manche Dinge die sind
unumkehrbar und kann ich jetzt sagen
wenn ich jetzt die richtige Reihenfolge
die richtige Ordnung der basishandlung
habe ist das dann die Gesamthandlung ja
oder ist die mehr als in Summe aller
Teile
wir kommen gleich auf die Diskussion
jedenfalls steht fest Handlungen müssen
koordiniert und komponiert sein
komponiert meint da muss es gewisse
Regeln geben bei denen die gehorchende
Handlung hat eine ganz klare Struktur
und wir müssen genau hinschauen das
nennt man die analytische
Handlungstheorie man kann also komplexe
Handlung analysieren in verschiedene
Teil oder basishandlung die ihrerseits
nicht weiter analysiert werden können
als Folge
schon noch basaleren Handlung und
Handlungen weisen eine raumzeitliche
Ausdehnung ab also
selbst wenn ich jetzt eine Schwarzwälder
Kirschtorte Backe nimmt diese Handlung
ein Raum meistens die Küche ich bewege
mich wohin ich muss Distanzen
zurücklegen ich muss in den Backofen
reinkommen da ist eine räumliche
Dimension enthalten und wie lange dauert
es eine Schwarzwälder Kirschtorte zu
backen das hängt natürlich davon ab wie
viel Mühe sie sich geben es gibt
natürlich die schnelle Variante ja da
kaufen die sich schon die vorgebackenen
Böden und tun nur noch ein bisschen
Sahne schlagen das wenn Sie ganz einfach
sich machen wollt kaufen sie sich die
Sahne einfach aus dem Supermarkt und
sprühen die drauf dann tun sie noch die
fertig Kirschen dazwischen und noch
irgendeine Füllung dann haben sie die
Sache in wenigen Minuten oder Sie machen
halt die ganz traditionelle
Schwarzwälder Kirschtorte alles
handgebacken sie backen die Böden selbst
ja das dauert lange ich würde mal sagen
zwei Stunden oder noch mehr das heißt
eine Handlung hat immer eine zeitliche
Ausdehnung
also wir haben gesehen es ist in
komplexes Phänomen mit diesem ganzen
analytischen
basishandlung und komplexen Handlungen
und jetzt wollen wir noch uns befassen
mit dem handlungsversuch also Handlung
können auch misslingen bzw verhindert
werden ja
ich kann etwas versuchen ich kann mich
entschließen etwas zu tun
aber dann kann es nicht gelingen ein
handlungsversuch setzt einen Schluss
beziehungsweise ein gewill gebildeten
will voraus und jetzt kann eine Handlung
aus verschiedenen Gründen misslingen zum
Beispiel wenn bei der Willensbildung
nicht genügend instrumentelle
Rationalität vorhanden war ja ich habe
einfach nicht lang genug nachgedacht ja
das kann ein Grund sein dann müssen wir
noch unterscheiden zwischen Handeln
beabsichtigen und wollen da bringe ich
noch mal den Spruch von Erich Kästner es
gibt nichts Gutes außer man tut es also
ist wenn ich eine Absicht einen guten
Wunsch habe eine gute Absicht habe ist
es schon gut oder muss ich die Absicht
auch noch in die Wirklichkeit umsetzen
also zu einer Handlung oder ist die
Absicht fassen zu Überzeugung gelangen
dass das getan werden sollte ist das
auch schon eine Handlung angenommen ich
bin der Meinung dass es
besser sei kein Fleisch zu essen
vegetarisch zu leben ich habe
Überzeugung und ich tue die Überzeugung
kund ich kommuniziert es überall in der
ganzen Welt
dann würde jemand Kombi Erich Kästner
sagen es gibt nichts Gutes außer man tut
es du kannst sie noch so viele erzählen
erzählen ist auch eine Hand aber du
kannst noch so viel erzählen dass du
Vegetarier bist wenn du dann am Ende
deinen Schnitzel isst bringt es gar
nichts ja du musst es auch praktizieren
ja also das ist die Frage hier gibt es
verschiedene Auffassung es gibt manche
Philosophen wie im amerikante vertreten
die These dass eine gute Willensbildung
also dass das den Willen zu bilden dass
das irgendwie auch schon gut ist kann
sagt gut ist allein ein guter Wille also
gute Motivation ist das entscheidende
und nicht die Handlung die daraus folgt
weil den Handlungen kann ich sowieso
nicht ansehen warum sie zustande
gekommen sind handlungs sind immer auch
irgendwie zufällig das ist jetzt so oder
so kann ich muss hinter die Handlung
schauen und das ist der Wille sagte man
wir kommen noch genauer darauf zu
sprechen jetzt würde ich gerne noch zum
Schluss mit ihm darüber diskutieren ob
Unterlassung Handlung sehen sie können
es versuchen meines Wissen klappt es
nicht mit
Ilias ich stelle das dann später noch
mal auf Youtube und auf Elias die Sache
sollte nicht funktionieren oder klappt
ja klappt genau dann machen wir das
hinterher man kann die Teilnehmenden
können dann schauen oder würde ich sagen
jetzt diskutieren wir einfach mal hier
noch zum Schluss
was der Unterschied ist ist unterlassen